let's pull this St from the hill ladies
and gentlemen the escalation is here
Texas Democrat calls on Biden to seize
control of Texas National Guard rep waen
Castro is calling on President Biden to
take control of the Texas National Guard
if the state defies a Supreme Court
ruling uh which it did Governor Greg
Abbott is using the Texas National Guard
to obstruct and create chaos at the
border if Abbott is defying yesterday's
Supreme Court ruling pus needs to
establish sole Federal control of the
Texas National Guard now he can't by the
way doesn't work that way the governor
has to sign off on federalization
basically saying like Okay through me
you can give orders and we can unify in
this
instance I I don't want to tell you guys
you have these people let me show you
this tweet this is Janai Nelson
president and direct counsel of ldf
NAACP legal defense and educational fund
saying this is outright Defiance of a
supreme court order by a southern
governor who thinks he is above the law
federalism means anything it means Greg
Abbott must be held to account let me
let me let me
make and let me make clear what we are
seeing now is Greg Abbott enforcing the
law to the best of his abilities walking
Castro and Democrats are lying about
what's going on saying it's chaos yeah
well he said that Greg is causing the
chaos it is chaos at the border they're
trying to stem the chaos the actions
being taken to old federal law and state
law is chaos the Biden Administration
and Democrats are actively destroying
this country and I I got to be honest
guys like I don't know I can't mince
words on this one they are quite
literally destroying the country this is
not I don't how do I say this they are
engaged in a seditious conspiracy to
subvert the Constitution and destroy the
fabric of this country that's not
hyperbole when when when Ian brings up
his parents who are not super
politically engaged and watch MSNBC
saying this is getting crazy when I I
bring up Chicago and New York because
when you have major Democrat strongholds
in panic over the crisis that is
happening right now and the Biden
Administration with a smile on his face
says the border is not secure and then
tries to damage it further there is no
question we are watching a man pour
lighter fluid on the fabric of this
nation and set it a flame while we all
scream the outcome here if the feds do
make a move to try and seize control of
the National Guard or deploy federal
agents Texas to try and stop them guys
what do you call it when armed forces
under State jurisdiction engage an
active conflict with Federal forces call
whatever you
want I don't know if if the if the
president I mean he's the commander-in
Chief of the Armed Forces I don't know
if the if the National Guard of Texas
would the guard of Texas would not under
his jurisdiction I don't think well I
mean the the feds can call them up they
called them up and sent them overseas
it's a question of where are these
Guardsmen from right are they residents
of Texas who enlisted in Texas I'd
imagine they'd have to be right yeah but
you but even still that like you don't
go to the same you you still go like
Army wherever the Army does their basic
training that doesn't that doesn't mean
anything in in the in in 1861 you had
West Point graduates trained in New York
saying my home is Virginia yeah and they
said I will and and that's I mean the
famous generals I will stand with my
state but I don't think that people
think like that anymore so I mean do you
think the 19-year-old guy whose mom
lives in I don't know Austin is going to
be like nah I'm going to go to war with
my with my neighbors and no idea what
your ear the what what a kid's going to
do I there are people there are people
like I would have said something
different before January 6 last year
when the when the feds filled up DC with
you know troops for no reason the
question is are these Guardsmen from
Texas and connected through Community to
Texas if the answer is yes there is no
question if the feds make a move against
Texas and try to seize control of the
guard on average people will always just
defend their friends and their families
yeah you're talking about what what
people are likely to do I'm wondering
what the law actually says apparently
and not I'm not a lawyer I'm reading
this from findlaw.com that title 32
gives Governors the authority over the
guard in their states but then they say
that title 10 says the president can
mobilize the guard and put it under
Federal Authority yes but under what
circumstances my understanding is the
governor has to sign off on it if that
if that's the case then if the governor
has to say yes then then that's the case
um but yeah I don't I don't know for
sure um well I mean I think
realistically the reason this country is
still alive is because states are
preeminent the federal government's an
afterthought like we are United States
we we unite by choice the Civil War
completely changed all of
that yeah it did that's that you like
what you're talking about is the way
that the the states thought of
themselves prior to the Civil War when
the states still thought that they could
secede yeah like they used to think
before like Texas in their Constitution
before they joined in their constitution
I believe it says we're reserving the
right to leave because Texas used to be
its own country so I think Texas could
secede theoretically so allegedly I
don't know that the federal government
would would allow it the feds might
still say no we settled this with the
with the Civil War according to to the
federal government the Civil War settled
the the question as to whether or not
countries can secede so and actually you
let say Grant wrote up exactly why they
cannot and I believe he's correct the
the so there are certainly uh uh he's
mostly correct he wrote this great
letter and he said basically the states
of the Union sacrificed blood and
treasure to admit these states to join
in and they owe a debt to declare that
they would separate while in debt is you
know I'm paraphrasing but you can read
the whole letter basically his point is
yo homie I paid a bunch of money for you
to come and and join this crew you can't
just bow out now you owe us and that
makes sense is that it I mean something
that effect is the argument being made
and so does that mean imp perpetuity
well that's a good point that's why I
say mostly correct mostly correct being
so long as you you you are in a Debt Pay
that debt back and we'll negotiate
however that is but I do believe that
ultimately it doesn't matter because uh
ulysis Grant also wrote
you are you have the right to secede but
no if you if there is a debt to be paid
you will be at War and if you lose
you'll be ruled by your uh by The
Victors so his his point is basically at
any point any person any any state could
declare they will no longer be part of
the Union but be prepared to fight and
if you lose you are now under under our
rule I imagine that they there will be a
there would be a fight if uh Texas were
to say well we're going to just kick
federal troops out it wouldn't be like
leaving uh the union it would be like yo
obviously fed Florida and Texas are
unified so if there was a union like
what's the union how many unions where
who is United exactly is it 49 of the
states decide to unify against this
stupid federal government that's gone
too far that then where's what's the
union the union is the people that are
unifying it's not doesn't it's not on
paper it's like what's really happening
right now I just I you know I just find
it fascinating how many people uh
scoffed at the idea of civil war and
then even after January 6 you still get
a lot of people say January 6 was not an
Insurrection but these Democrats who
claim it is still scoff at the idea of
civil war right now you have I'm I'm I'm
sorry my friends we quite literally have
the lowest degree possible but we do
have armed conflict between a State
National Guard and the federal
government now I want to be careful here
because I don't want people to assume
armed conflict implies people are
at each other what this means
is both factions have
deployed armed personnel and they are in
conflict with each other meaning Texas
National Guard are defying Federal
mandate and pushing out uh uh uh federal
agents to take territory the feds want
that territory back the only thing that
hasn't happened is they've not decided
to fight about it yet physically but
there are armed men in Conflict right
now trying to control certain
jurisdictions I mean this is a PO
it's it's
certainly far more significant than
January 6th was January 6th it was a
riot that got out of hand this is Jo Joe
Biden is engaged in Insurrection this I
mean that's look look I I think it is
definitive at this point Joe Biden
should be removed from the boutot in as
many states as he can for for engaging
in Insurrection actively right now by
subverting the Constitution and engaging
in a seditious conspiracy of human
smuggling and Defiance of even blue
states to make any argument that Trump
engaged in Insurrection and to then make
the argument that that Biden has not is
completely ridiculous and un serious see
I don't think they're actually going the
federal government is actually going to
go down to Texas and seize the National
Guard because I think they would
legitimately have a civil war at hands
because Texas would like not they
wouldn't allow that and so why would the
federal government especially in an
election year go down there and do
something because then the problem would
get 10 times worse and I think to your
point of you know Eric Adams and 50% of
the hotel rooms are taken up by illegal
immigrants and we have this huge crisis
in our country why would he continuously
make it worse I honestly think it's a
political play just to paint Texas and
Greg Abbott like the bad guys do
something why would they make it worse
so that Donald Trump can't win an
election in November that's true the
purpose that so you know we were talking
before the show Ian was saying they they
would not be able to win a Civil War I
mean it's ridiculous I'm like they would
because the wind condition is not like
one side climbs the top of the hill and
plants a flag
the win condition for people who hate
America is to destroy the fabric of the
country starting a civil war is the win
condition for these people so when I
hear people say like National divorce
I'm like that will be civil war there is
no circumstance where there is a
peaceful separation of States impossible
because of water rights because of
farming rights because of Highway access
because of weapon control because of
General natural resources which states
have access to I mean come on the North
Dakota fra Fields would become an
economic Powerhouse and then you're
going to have someone in a a different
state being like I'm the one who paid
for all of that and they're going to say
no we you're going to get Conflict for
sure if we do there will be no
Constitution anymore right in in the
Civil War in 1861 Abraham Lincoln
suspended habus Corpus in a corridor
stretching from DC up to Pennsylvania
the reason being Maryland was a slave
state with massive Southern uh uh uh
sympathies so he had members of their
legislature arrested and created a
corridor where they could travel between
DC and Pa so the union could stay
unified with DC and they would arrest
anyone without charge or trial who in
any way bothered them and there's
actually one guy they did locked him up
for the duration of the war and he gave
him the middle finger and said f you
when the war ended they let him go and
then he just said f you and they were
like your charges stand said f you and
he he left and then that was like they
just let it go who is it you can read
about the story it was crazy Abraham
Lincoln when the war started
Constitution was gone yeah if you were
if you were a speaking Pro Confederacy
speech you're locked up done no question
if a civil war were to break out the I
mean let me let me just tell you do you
guys think let me ask you a question the
Epstein Client List let's say there's a
person we know that they're ultra
wealthy individuals and Powerful they're
on The Client
List do you which would you think they
would prefer having their name published
in the press as to being a high-profile
billionaire pedophile who was working
with Epstein or Civil War breaking the
machine apart what do you think these
people would rather have happened oh
Civil War they they don't want to be
exposed yeah absolutely they don't want
accountability they don't want to get
caught they want to keep up their
operations keep up the crimes they're
committing and they'd rather the United
States burn and they want find out what
they're doing I mean that's what they
want to destabilize Western Civilization
as we know it and they want to destroy
the Constitution but that's all coming
from the wef they've been wanting to do
this for decades of just continuously
destabilize our country as we know it
take our freedom slowly but shortly and
I mean even now gen Z they will they're
willing to do anything to make a dollar
and theyve they don't even have a care
about politics or what's going on in our
country until so you actually show them
the amount of college kids actually that
I interview asking if they even know
about the Border crisis or how many
people are coming into our country or
that their taxpayer dollars are paying
for it in whether it's in San Diego
California or Texas so many kids have no
idea because they don't watch the news
all they watch is brainwashing on Tik
Tok and they don't actually know the the
crisis is going on you know a lot of
people have made the joke that
everything started to fall apart when
Epstein
died and there's a meme that around the
time Epstein dies you get the breakdown
of narrative control you get the
lockdowns you get I mean people start
losing their minds now I certainly don't
think that means that whatever Epstein
was doing was the the top of the
mountain in terms of this deep state or
I I I like the new phrase that we're
getting from the K Lake scenario people
back East what did he what did he say oh
that what a video yeah people back East
that guy resigned by the way he did he
did resign we'll definitely talk about
that but I'm wondering if whatever it is
ab's involved in has scattered the
Cockroaches dude and that's and this is
why the narrative machine is breaking
because it used to be that high-profile
Millionaires and billionaires and
politicians were all partying and then
once abine gets caught they all say
every man for themselves yeah yeah it
feels like abject Panic it does feel
like that like that Panic that I can't
see but I can sense that it's happening
happening behind the scenes cuz it's so
quiet it's so quiet about that fene
stuff too quiet yeah I think so too I
mean come on we know powerful people on
that list they're going to be heads of
Industry they're going to be politicians
they're going to be world leaders it
could be Bill Clinton like Andrew like
I've heard that Bill Clinton literally
flew with EP scene a bunch of times
probably got massages from 15year Olds
God knows what else they did uh I'm not
know if probably is the right word but
like that if it was Bill if you found
the Bill Clinton of all people it's like
the grossest underage sex scandal on
Earth and then you're implicating people
like Bill like what in the what is that
bro prince Andrew is photographed with
one of thece of England yeah Prince of
the of the United Kingdom I mean this is
already that serious think about how
look man you look at you you look at
like the Emirates you look at uh uh
Saudi Arabia you look at the wealth
that's down there you think these people
aren't also connected and I'm not saying
all of them I'm just saying there are
criminal corrupt people with massive
amounts of power probably working with
Epstein Epstein the whole things broken
whatever machine they had running I'm
not saying it was the machine I'm not
saying it was the Deep state but too
many people associated with powerful
industry and government were involved in
that and they're scattering like
cockroaches the light got turned on and
they rushed to the corners of the room
and now there's nothing maintaining the
facade I mean I feel like the Epstein
was was a uh an Intel asset and so I
mean that's kind of what would happen if
or that's what you would expect to
happen if you know if he actually did
have you know information on powerful
people and stuff like that and they were
using it as state secrets to to get
compliance or whatever they're going to
try to squash the list that Intel
agencies don't want anyone to know about
what they're doing ever like they just
that's just everything is as secret as
they can get I was picturing Tim you
were talking about EP getting off the
plan with like some dude I keep using
Bill Clinton or whoever it was some
random guy and he's like you like her a
lot man yeah she really likes you she's
15 bro we got you and then like Epstein
just seizes Alpha control of Bill
Clinton or whoever the emotional control
and and then they're like what I can't
even say he's got this thing that I
don't want him to have cuz it's like
can't even acknowledge that he's got the
thing I mean I imagine it's like he's on
the plane cuz they cu the reports are
that the girls were on the planes and he
invites someone like Clinton or whoever
it may be they're sitting on the plane
and then they say like hey meet this uh
hot young thing and then she starts
working on them and then one she's done
he says hey take a look at the TV screen
we got a movie we're going to play and
then he plays the video of it happening
and he goes by the way she's 15 we got
all of it man and just like the the the
balls that Epstein had and then as soon
as you say that that politician that
corporate officer or whatever they start
sweating profus like what do you mean
it's like don't worry relax I'm going to
call you and tell you what you what you
need to do when I need you to do it but
everything should be fine you work for
us
now how many people are bought in this
country that we have no idea about and
and I don't think we're ever going to
actually see the entire list because
once they're all implicated and you know
I think they should go to prison for the
rest of their lives uh it's going to
cause so much havoc in our country and
they don't want that list to come out
nobody does no like that's that's my
whole feeling on the whole Intel thing
like as long as it's connected to
intelligence you're going to have media
and governments doing everything they
can to shut it down and and what would
they rather have the list coming out
with their names on it or a civil war
Civil War plus I think they know the
list and let's not even say Civil War to
be honest would destabilization to the
point where there is no power able to
hold them accountable let me put it this
way if this country if Donald Trump
wins come November and then the list
does come out Bill Clinton's on it do
you think Democrats would believe or
care or even try to go after Clinton no
no they would they would lie about
what's going on they would say Donald
Trump fabric ated a list to try and go
after his political Rivals dude that's
it they I mean this is why the Boston
Globe published that story where they
said Democrats wore gamed out what would
happen in 2020 and in the event Donald
Trump were to win they would encourage
west coast states to secede from the
union this literally happened it's
Boston Globe this is this this story
comes out in what like I think uh uh uh
mid 2020 this is where we are now thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net